[Musique]
votre mari est plus âgée que vous n'en a
exactement même âge en a juste trois
mois de différence alors donc ça pose
pas problème
et si vous auriez épouser un homme plus
jeune que vous oui je mens pas
l'inconvénient s'il m'avait plu et tout
oui je compte à la différence
si les plus jeunes est ce que c'est vous
trouvez ça gênant non pas du tout
puisque de toute façon mon fiancé est
plus jeune que moi pour vivre à deux ou
même âge il faut néanmoins d'imagination
alors vous pensez avec une différence
d'âge importante pour une femme enfant
par rapport à moi c'est à dire plus âgés
ne sentirait pas capable c'est surtout
dans les les couples plus solides sont
quand même les agents rapport est en
harmonie dans l'ensemble je le crois
bien que vous pensez que c'est l'homme
qui doit être le plus âgé en principe
oui pour pouvoir guider la femme on
vient les choses et vous mes côtés ben
oui je peux pas dire le contraire parce
que nous avons eu huit ans d'écart alors
voyez vous et ça fait presque 20 ans que
nous sommes mariés nous avons pris comme
au premier jour
je pense que la finale des deux plus
jeunes j'ai près sûr que je préfèrerais
que l'homme je fréquente soit plus âgés
c'est plus un confort attend si vous me
dire on n'a plus confiance peut-être
c'est vraiment fait ça je crois que
c'est une image traditionnelle parce que
la jeune fille est beaucoup plus attirés
vers un homme plus âgé enfin ben je te
vois pas l'utilité que l'homme soit plus
vieux que la femme parce qu'il a déjà
suffisamment tendance à être
paternaliste comme ça c'est pas la peine
de lui donner une possibilité de plus de
jouer les bons pape ans je pense qu'une
égalité d'âge et la solution heureuse
enfin que pour la femme au contraire
elle est davantage soyez
mieux compris ce qu'était l'homme est
plus haché qu'elles n'ont pas du tout
pas notre époque maintenant non on sent
pas une trop grande différence quand
maman jusqu'à 10 ans à peu près il
voyait pas aimer quelqu'un de très
jeunes n'ont quoi parce que j'ai besoin
de sécurité et que j'ai l'impression que
quelque quelqu'un de plus jeune ne
pourrais pas me donner cette sécurité
mais quelqu'un de trop à agir enfin que
quinze à vingt ans de plus ça me
gênerait aussi mais vous auriez pas
quelqu'un de beaucoup plus jeune que
vous non ça peut arriver ça ne
m'arrivera plus en étant jeune on n'y
pense pas et puis quand vient l'âge de
la vieillesse ça doit se voir là je
pense que l'homme recherche plutôt une
femme qu'il domine un peu peut-être
enfin à lyon
ou peut-être toutefois je réserve que
certains hommes sont encore de grands
enfants et que quelquefois si la femme
est plus âgé ça peut donner quand même
de certains coûts vous ne feriez pas
aimer un homme plus jeune que vous
enfin je pourrais l'emea pleinement au
mapaq pour voir ce que c'est là
l'équilibré d'un ménage crois que c'est
essentiel que l'homme soit plus cher que
la somme pourquoi apprendre enfin c'est
pas ce tir tout à cause de la situation
un homme qui hébergeait qui me femmes
végétation établi en principe donc
arriver à maintenir un ménage syndicats
c'est londres qui est plus jeune
est ce que maintenant il ya des femmes
qui arrivent aussi avoir situations
avant leur mari mais après ça crée un
déséquilibre est ce que vous auriez
épouser un homme beaucoup plus jeune que
vous non non je ne pense pas non
personnellement non pourquoi j'ai besoin
de quelqu'un qui est plus mûr que moi
parce que je considère que l'homme est
en charge des familles je préfère avoir
un mari
les injections n'auriez pu aimer une
femme plus âgée que vous
non je peux pas est ce que vous pensez
qu'une femme âgée avec un homme très
jeune et ridicule non pourquoi pas il
n'y a pas de coupe le ridicule ce n'a
aucune espèce d'importance et le projet
ya une question de sentiment qu'ils
jouent personnellement j'ai trois ans
différence avec mon mari et je suis plus
vieille que mon mari et je trouve pas
que ça de l'importance il faut quand un
groupe 100 ans l'âge n'a pas
d'importance pense pas surtout qu'au
contraire c'est merveilleux
[Musique]